you don't want to stick fingers up your
Lincoln's bedroom let's go
[Music]
hi I'm H Foley I'm 511 and I'm rooting
for the part of pizza delivery man
[Laughter]
this is answer the internet yeah would
you rather have free strippers for life
or free pizza for life
my banging the strippers can I be blunt
or is it just lap dances and
it like we get to [__] everybody do you
believe in your game you're gonna get us
here okay I'll go with the pizza yeah
I'm not always in the mood for strippers
but I am always in the mood for a Frozen
song yeah
oh it was free pizza I thought it was
frozen pizza oh free regular pizza yeah
[__] out of here I'll be at Joe's every
day
not giving up strippers for a Stouffer's
French Bread I thought it was frozen
pizza yeah
I do like it though shout out to him
let's see would you give up an inch of
penis like no
would you give up an inch of penis
length for an inch of height absolutely
[__] not what do you mean I got a
skeleton crew down there as it is yeah
but are you nuts I'll go three inches
shorter yeah for whatever I would lose
an inch to add an inch yeah for sure
would you yeah dude dude did you take
that deal you got an inch just laying
around that's crazy
let them see that extra inch on the Dom
yeah slipping out of their seats all
right yeah I'm not giving up anything
yeah you're funny if you could pick one
country to run what would it be
uh something uh like Finland or
something they got a lot of cash they
don't need an army it's probably real
real laid back do the sauna and [__] in
the morning a cold plunge that's the
[__] game that's a great answer I
don't want to go to war I just want to
[__] chill with the boys you know
what I mean
Colombia next one
you'll be really [__] assassinated in
like two days
my people will love me
yeah a little kid if you were murdered
who would be the most likely suspect hi
I'm Kevin Ryan nice to meet you
probably a mozzarella stick
my mom
would probably hate me the most right
whoever knows me the best I'd be him or
my girlfriend what are we talking about
yeah I can see that
I can see that but rat poisoning he's Dr
Pepper if you could live inside of one
TV show what would you live in this is a
great [__] question it thinks about
this is something that I've thought
about since I was a kid we didn't have
cable when I was young I was always
jealous of Nickelodeon and Disney
Channel I wanted to live on one of those
shows I always wanted to live in that
reality go to school outside the
lunchroom was always outside
um if I had to though
I'd [__] The A Team I'd want to be on
the squad with the boys he immediately
wants to go to battle who that's so not
chill I get to hang out Mr T
ower to helicopters and Hand Grenades
what hanging out with [__] a bunch of
Vietnam Vets [__] running around the
country with AKs and a sick fan I would
be a [__] Bayside High all guys at
the max getting the burger yeah doing it
up giving Screech a wedgie selling weed
to the kids all right what is the
youngest age child that could beat you
up man I see some like real rough 12
year olds on the subway yeah that would
give me or I'm like if he gets mad
enough I'd be [__] yeah well dude you
see some 12 year olds with a mustache
and [__] that's it right they're 12 they
got a mustache like a SpongeBob t-shirt
on they're still ready to [__] you up my
nephew's 10 he's pretty strong I
wouldn't [__] with him in his Squad you
get an Italian kid who hit puberty yeah
these kids got all the [__]
antibiotics in them who knows what they
got I'll be [__] you up yeah a 12
year old could run [__] on a lot of
people young kids and old dudes I don't
[__] with old dudes either some Korean
war vet knock me the [__] out yeah
salt pepper combo
feel like the [__] Irish guy and
[__] Notre Dame if every time you got
a boner the same song would start
playing what song would you want The
Boys Are Back in Town
Ah that's pretty good
um Battle of the Edmund Fitzgerald
it only come when I'm crying
shipwrecks get me going
[__] Piano Man something nice do you
think the president jerks off in the
Oval Office I would yeah you gotta just
to say they did it that's like moving
forward new apartment you got to
Christen it right away I mean
hasn't got in there January 2nd whatever
the inauguration is knocked one out real
quick
for sure with the [__] blinds open
you kidding me hey [__] you the Free
World
he looks like a saint compared to his
sons
I'd be doing that top shelf in the
toilets the whole nine yards his [__]
yeah this is my place for the next four
years
[__] that ruining your own bathroom yeah
you got it dude oh that's only so many
people can jerk off at the Oval Office
in a lifetime you gotta do it dude
lifetime arguably right 46 yeah 46. you
gotta figure I'm sure some Secret
Service guys have done it or whatever
I would what are you talking about man
you're around you it's like yeah it's
like landed on the moon you gotta
[__] you gotta take it out for a spin
what if you miss
someone what is it what do they say who
gives a [__] what if the first lady
finds that comes blocks in the office
and she's like I am [__] better than
you have her whacked whatever calling a
[__] drone strike you don't want to
stick fingers up your butt in Lincoln's
bedroom let's [__] go yeah what are
you crazy got to that's how I yeah if
I'm at the fireplace going and
everything nice crackle and fire yeah
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out